[Music]
yeah this is comedians without cars
getting sodas and today our vehicle of
choice to pick up our comedian who well
hasn't really made it is the lime
scooter it was invented and developed in
[ __ ] Williamsburg Brooklyn
what a [ __ ] hellhole that is and it
was invented about around the Year I
don't know a couple of weeks ago but it
seems like forever if you live in a
small town you probably might not have
seen one yet however if you're from a
big city like me and Stevie you see them
and likely hate the people who ride them
these scooters are for people who don't
have lives bisexual steamed their body
they go both ways that always ya know
they do survive well I
we need you sorry sorry Steve dude dude
this is the lizard people for people
podcast yeah yeah lizard okay well good
luck with that I'm sorry Steve I'm so C
can you finish it finish the show how do
you want one day Steve no we no we won't
no we won't you're watching comedians
without cars getting soda enjoy it Sam
thank you for coming all right so we're
done dude well we didn't do a car I want
to show you we're gonna do these lime
scooters you know we don't have cars
you know the show no no no wait you know
we wanted a lime scooter for you that
gig economy yeah is such a [ __ ] up
economy it's so bad this is a mobile
prison and we thought you'd be the
perfect guest I mean this is just the
greatest [ __ ] example of you know
what's going on in our call
yeah I mean not only is this like I
don't own anything but now they're
collecting my data that's right you have
to put all right guys let's go
here we hadn´t something what forgetting
something oh [ __ ] my helmet yeah my
helmet hey could I get my helmet all
right yeah now this has been specially
fitted for me sure I feel like does
anybody look fantastic Eddy you look
like a broke cosmonaut anybody else feel
like this society holds a carrot in
front of us like a carrot and stick you
know okay let's go guys let's go just a
distraction
yeah so Sam yeah where did you start
your career I started Las Vegas - no way
when I started bro there was one open
mic every other week you've been mic
every other week every other week we're
here this was on 93 holy [ __ ]
that's exactly what it was like where I
started you had to go 60 miles to the
other open mic yeah dude that sounded
like the bass old man story back a mom
we go 60 miles to an open mic we're
gonna have it in every coffee shop now
Vegas so did you grow up in Vegas no I
grew up in upstate New York
okay which is like I called ghetto
country buddy like hood farmers we have
like we have cow farms and meth labs a
Johnny sex cult just was in my area
Sam what was your first five minutes
like did you run through some of that so
funny dude the first joke I ever did was
about how women give handjobs like this
trying to saw it lawnmowers and I crush
dude I crushed all right who doesn't
love you know the good hand job joke
right but after that knew the next night
I bombed I bombed so hard
like heroin withdrawal like a sense of
security oh yeah I thought I was the
chosen one I'm like I should just quit
now I'm on the top I just crushed a
coffee shop in Las Vegas I crushed the
coffee shop in Vegas this is by the way
a very treacherous situation I don't
even know what we're doing I don't
either
all millage men act like we got health
insurance so Sammy Vegas seems like
living on the moon to me yeah is it like
that like I called Vegas blue-collar LA
like it's a lane without but everybody
has a day job right and then I call
Tampa Bay a sleazebag babe what Oh God
okay all right we have with some free
even lizard people did are everywhere so
I started in Vegas and I would do comedy
every right dude I started producing my
own shows before the internet dude right
more like the internet was what it is
today so I got to get off Flyers
everywhere every long dude I was part of
the flyer culture too kids don't get it
boy we had the print we had to do flyer
what a pain in the ass flyers [ __ ] it
was him Mitch Hedberg joke is like
basically fire saying hey we can throw
this out for this Basin I had to give my
parents a flyer to love me I was like
haha can
will you love me and it was done by
flyer whereas today kids can email their
parents
oh is this us for a killing sure here we
are here we are we have arrived
[Music]
alright guys so yeah this is the place
this is where you get your lottery
tickets yeah I get my lottery tickets
here I've been here for while they did
look at this look at how great this is
great
sit down I just want to do the old man
soda-can Joy your refresh good guy
refresco it's amazing some of the worst
hookers I've ever seen a right over
there look at that got a guy in a
wheelchair point out that we're all
hookers and all and realize okay so
Sammy we're talking about your career
we're talking about the Comedy Store you
have some great story oh yeah that was
your worst gig what was your worst gig
the worst gig I ever did was probably
well I mean for me it's becoming a
comedian that was the work that's the
worst decision I have this story about
the time I was working with Vince Vaughn
Oh
bombed so badly really I get a call from
I get called from this hey dude we need
you to do we want you to do this benefit
I'm like sweet it's in Dewey Beach it's
at a rock club okay it's first-come
first-serve
the bar opens at noon in his sold-out at
noon the shows not till 8:00 at night so
people are getting fun okay right this
is the closer I'll ever be the beat of
Beatle was hanging out with rich we've
been [ __ ] we got a bus women would just
just run off the street into the bus the
guys would be like what the [ __ ] just
happened so we get to this a band will
show up
I was drinking at that point I was so
nervous I did about he used to take me
about five Jack's shots to just get
going under hold it you were so was this
how deep into your career was this that
you were I would just start okay I get
it you were alcohol oh I am an alcoholic
and a drug addict well sex addict I'm
addict at least you have different
avenues to channel these things in well
just a man that self that like dude I
one time I was addicted to buying Go
Daddy
domain names I'd like 200 domain I was
just buying on this might be a domain
I'd sell at some point I'm sober now and
you only have about 30 GoDaddy now yeah
alright so good story so I go up and
they're like hey you go up next I'm like
okay I'll get this crowd I'm a bar
I won't borders considered the greatest
bar gig comic of all time like I could
just handle bars because I grew up in
Vegas and you would have to go up and
just play bars because they local clubs
wouldn't playoffs so I go up and I just
light up all the hecklers shut everybody
up and get the show going
so they go up so I'm going up I'm doing
okay I'm doing my stand-up I go into the
stripper in a wheelchair bit which was
my classic bit from way back in the day
this chick in the front goes you're not
funny get off stage and dude I go red
line right I'm like watch your [ __ ] up
watch you and leave here and go [ __ ] one
of your cousin's here well it turns out
she's with into the entire bar is all
her friends and family and bringing hard
dude and they bow [ __ ] he's got all
[ __ ] flew and he's got his friend
wave the flag that's a little drummer
boy in the back Bob I blame the guilt
stage I'm like Chuck that up to now the
after-party
the entire cast of the wedding crashers
are there the woman from the wedding
crashers the lead actress is a nice
person she's trying to talk me off a
ledge right I can't hear what she's
saying cuz she's like Charlie Brown's
mom at this point won't want want more
I'm not listening because I just see
that old Wilson going how many levels of
nose does this guy have and I just
bombed in front I mean it is really yeah
it's like a hollow oh my god
it looks like something from that
screams yeah I mean you finally cute and
that that was probably the worst game I
love that all right guys let's get back
on the scooters let's go in the bath two
machines No
the death machines there we go you're
like when they say a quarterback is a
coach on the field
Sam this is kind of a personal question
but if you if you didn't have the
podcast and you just had the stand-up
could you make a living could you make
ends meet with just the standard a I
mean it would be way more difficult it
would be complete let me tell you
something dude
yeah the podcast is the best the biggest
blessing of my life yeah I dude I do
tinfoil hat shows with my buddy Eddie
Bravo and my co-host XG yeah dude I get
on stage I'm like holy [ __ ] I'm getting
like Bert Kreischer laughs that's great
yeah would you do the rope yeah like
it's packed with people and I always
think God dude are they here for me or
they just here for Eddie and the lot of
them are there for Eddie because that
he's great right you really are getting
everybody knows you ha ha baby but that
is very cool oh my thing my thing's gone
what do you mean the energy the the
scooters not going hey Eddie my scooters
dead
Eddie Eddie Eddie come back we lost
Steve we lost Steve we lost another
soldier so Sammy that was great Sam just
got recognized by a tinfoil hat fan oh
we gotta cross we gotta cross okay let's
see
do it go go go go Speed Racer
whoa Oh Eddie are you okay
my scooter went out thank god Brian was
here to pick me up
scooter went out guys just kept going
they kept going kind of feels like a
metaphor for where were you oh you guys
left me you guys ditched me and and you
fell Eddie you see see what happens
thanks for doing this Sam anytime dude
anytime yeah you're our first choice by
the way hold on hold on
what the hell is this this is product
placement brenton we don't have any
money for you do you like the impossible
burger we don't have money for it this
generations [ __ ]
[Music]
you